if I were to ask you what are the
hardest things in life to have or
experience what would you say today I'm
going to share with you the four that I
believe are the most difficult things to
find in life a natural way to be a host
evaluate a man weekend today I want to
talk to about four the most difficult
things in life to experience in my
opinion first one is this I was top on
my father he always told me says Patrick
you're gonna know a lot of people you
can have a lot of friends you're gonna
have a lot of acquaintances but he said
one great friend weighs more is valued
more than thousands of people you may
know in your life one great friend one
great friend that you know is worth more
than thousands of people you may have in
your life he said it's one of the
hardest things to find in life as
somebody who's a great from because life
changes and you change and you grow and
if you have somebody else has grown with
you accepting your lovin on you all
those deep-rooted experiences that is
less judgment you know you did this you
did that he's more important there's a
pure real relationship accepting that
both people are going through
experiences in life one the hardest
things to find and that person who is a
friend of yours if you only treat him
like a friend and somebody who is not a
blood or somebody who is not as
important to you as a family member you
will generally lose that person so if a
person gets to that level of a great
friend love them and treat them like
family because they are as valuable as
that it's very hard to find second thing
it's finding a great partner and a
spouse it's got to be one of the most
difficult things to do because when you
find this person this person's got to
know your weaknesses he or she is gonna
know your flaws your challenges your
problems your herbs you're not cleaning
the bathroom or you know the stuff that
no one else knows about your clothes are
everywhere your socks are everywhere you
mismatched you know doing your clothes
laundry dirty clothes food how you eat
your plate you know everyone's got
something your temper your the way you
flare your attitude sometimes the way
you get quiet to yourself you
wanna talk you do this but they love on
you because they're a great spouse
they're a great partner it's somebody
who doesn't criticize you publicly but
they do criticize you privately it's
somebody who may back you up publicly
but privately when they want to say
something they're police on and say
honey I got to tell you something I
think what you did today wasn't right I
think you should reconsider that it's
somebody that doesn't create more
paranoia in your life it's someone that
strengthens your relationships around
you it's a very very hard thing to find
and that's a great partner great spouse
number three it's a great cause that
you're passionate about a Great Crusade
something that's very few people and
life experience you know as I 2008 was
the year where I really wanted to find
out what was the cause that Patrick
David was meant to do and this didn't
mean I needed to change a industry and
go from try to go into real estate or
try to go become a doctorate writer
that's not at all cause doesn't have to
do with occupation cause is a byproduct
of what your occupation allows you to
put time and effort into this cause and
if we can find a way to combine the two
together even better but when you find
out your cause you're introduced to a
person you've never met before a lot of
times people ask my sister Pat how do I
find out my purpose my cause my crusade
something that fires me up one of the
best books I read on this subject was by
a British diplomat it was titled
leaderless revolution and he said
there's three ways to find out what your
purpose and your cause is number one you
got to make a list of things you hate
you've heard the same before whatever
you don't hate you learn to tolerate so
what do you hate in life maybe you
experienced something as a kid maybe you
experienced something as a nation when
you watch the country the direction it's
going what do you hate what bothers you
write it down you you're bothered by
young kids who are taking advantage of
you're bothered by traffic and you're
bothered by something what is it three
what do you love make a list of things
that you love you love kids you know you
love whatever maybe something that you
love generally when you make that list
you find something so wait a minute
there's something deeper there and you
can go into it and introduce you to a
whole different side and you notice your
belly changes you think different your
heart changes you get excited and the
last most
last but not least most difficult thing
to find in life in my opinion is a great
group of people to run with I was in the
Army there's nothing like being part of
a unit that we had camaraderie I can't
explain it to you I didn't need to make
$50,000 a month or a million dollars a
month to be happy in the Army they paid
me 800 bucks a month and I was fulfilled
because we are made to be part of a
community we are made to be part of
another group of people that strengthen
us that make us whole
this person is veteran this and I'm
better in this and together we're great
then we can go against whatever bigger
force because it's an army of one and
and we have each other's back and we
push each other we challenge each other
we upset each other we annoy each other
at times but we know when we're looking
at each other there's that level of
respect knowing you gave everything in
and I gave everything in and we're in
this think thinking thing together and
it's a sincere no backstabbing games
I've been part of that as well I'm
talking a since see a real genuine group
of people they can run with for the rest
your life one of the hardest things to
find in life when you find those four
things don't take him for granted
because they're very difficult to find
however they're not attracted to force
they're attracted to somebody who is
attracting to them okay so you can't
force a friend you can't force a great
spouse you can't force a great cause you
can't force a great group of people
they're attracted to you you worked on
you they're attracted to you the more
clear you are about what you want the
more clear you are about the sense of
direction you go on in your life and all
of a sudden these four elements appear
in your life one by one by one it's not
going to come on your terms it never
comes on our terms but it does show up
to the person that's clear about what
they're going in their life it's my
message into week two in if you feel
compelled to share this video with
somebody else that they need to hear
please do so thanks for watching this
video
you